when you've had a child for someone else
especially I will say majority of men
Legacy is very important do not yes
there's a lot of baby mamas around okay
okay hold on hold on and then this fools
in with the age thing as well because as
we're saying the old you're getting the
more Barren you're becoming so then
because you're older you should accept
that a man will cheat on you is that is
that what we're saying you could dial on
too so yeah but we've done that's the
point guys like not every woman is a man
like it does it want to step out step
out like when we are fatty that's my
value when you say oh you know 20
anymore so you don't have any value no I
actually my value is that I can stand by
my own I can pay my bills I'm
independent and this is because I'm 30
because when I was 20 I was probably
looking for a man to you know help me
out in you know just to in order to are
you gonna be happy 60 without a family
yourself yeah because in in the world I
can do a lot of things okay I can I can
if I cannot have my own baby I can adopt
it I can have a pet I can do whatever
else I'm not just a bloody baby machine
honestly
I'm not a baby machine so my value
doesn't depend from how many eggs
do you want children though I don't know
I still don't I'd never found a man that
let me think okay let's have a baby
still so if I don't know I don't I don't
want to have a child I don't think my
life gonna be
saddle with the right man
if you find the right man
right at 35. yeah you get in a
relationship at 35. when are you going
to think about having a child I don't
know that can happen in six months that
can happen in two years time that's not
uh you know calendar and we don't
planify our life day by day that things
just happens and I just don't feel like
I'm less valuable than 20 years old I'm
just different so did you know one out
of three women under 30 have fertility
issues one out of everything our food is
different today so so I don't even know
if I want to tell you so like so I I
know but I'm saying for the right guy so
if you found the guy that that you would
have a kid with like that that's more of
a risk when you're older yeah it's free
to go with a 20 years old if you just
won't think about me as a baby machine
it's free to go either 20 years old girl
I'm fine
I'm just conscious about my age exactly
happy yeah yeah we're talking about baby
right now so I just answer the question
you're values yeah my value I'll explain
to you I explained to you just now that
my value is not about how many when men
I slept with is not about how many eggs
I contain steel because I'm not a baby
machine my value is about how many money
I can make because I probably can make
more money than I meant out there it's
about it's about what I can deal with
life every day I don't need a man this
is my value okay I stand by my own this
is my value so the question is can you
find a man that can stand next to me and
deal with me yeah but when you say
that's your value to him that's it who's
that yeah for me I don't I don't know
like when you're selling something she
talking about cars when you're selling
something is you you decide the value of
your entire Market the market does so so
okay that's like me saying okay I'm Envy
like an NVA y an NBA player that's like
that's like okay stop stop interrupting
me that's that's like me saying that I
can get a top one percent guy so I would
say I deserve a guy that can that can
makes half a million but none are lining
up to buy me then I'm not I'm not worth
that that's your value and so so you
can't just tell men oh I'm still just as
valuable but you just did you just went
off
I gonna repeat clearly so I know very
clearly what I want okay now as as you
said probably I'm not available so I
don't want to get what I want cool I
stay by my horn I don't need a man like
oh I get what I want I guess I can just
say buy my own I don't need a man I know
the other child I'm like a person I'm
not a baby machine I'm not uh you know
what I mean like that's my values I
stand by my own for what you're saying
you don't sound very happy about that no
I just don't I'm not very happy about
how another other women can think about
our body and our essence
and then she's saying the value that she
brings to the man that is approaching
her whether he chooses to go to her or
on once a 20 whatever obviously he's
approached us so he likes her so that's
the value that she brings that's that's
the point I'm saying I've never talked
about you guys I don't know
but the question is is that fair to
expect monogamy so I'm saying over a
certain age you're less valuable to man
and then as soon as I say as soon as I
say that you guys get triggered no no
and you guys you keep you keep
interrupting this is this is my this is
this is this is my this is she no no no
I'm saying when she starts
stop this is rude this is my show it's
very rude to interrupt the host okay
like so so sorry like this is
disrespectful sorry carry on and so I'm
saying that if you're going to men and
telling them what they should value and
every time I say this is what men value
you guys you keep arguing with it then
you want to say well what are my best
years this this this and this I get that
but I'm just saying she asked the
question and said that this girl said
she's 30 and then you said you're 30. so
when you get to 30 you made it personal
about her but I don't know why no no
sorry I don't know Auntie's name but
yeah she said once she gets to 35 and
then her eggs blah blah blah she asked
her something personal about her so
that's why it got personal because you
made it about honestly that's why she
was talking about herself and not saying
that you expect all men to accept this
value blah blah blah the point is if if
a certain man approaches her and this is
the value that she gives or she brings
and the guy doesn't want it then that's
fine I can understand that you're saying
that this is men want XYZ men want
um whatever you said from a certain age
or whatever as if to say no man
approaches a 30 or 35 five-year-old
woman when there's two 30 year old women
sat here who men approach but there's a
difference between like four set like
like it doesn't count unless you get
into a brain none of it counts together
yeah it doesn't it doesn't yeah you can
be approached your number can be taken
your Instagram can be got but if you're
not being kept it doesn't matter fair
enough you can tell any man I get moved
to 10 times a day cool all right do you
have a man no maybe we don't I remember
because we don't want men like the
majority of the men okay so it's not
about you taking women it's about we
like each other we find you know the
match so you cannot talk about we might
as someone they've been taken yeah but
again
I learned something today yeah yeah
auntie we me and Auntie had a
conversation RT explained to me I said
are you in a relationship she said yeah
I'm in a relationship and I said does
that so does that mean you're not part
of the 35 and over leftover women which
was a topic that we were speaking about
at the time and she went I'm still part
of that category and I said I don't get
it like you're in a relationship you've
you've made it and she went no I have
I've got I haven't got a ring so I'm
still a part of that category and I
didn't get it because I was like why
you're in a committed relationship
you're where you well because I'm in a
committed relationship I'm a leftover oh
I'm a leftover in a committed
relationship yes that was it and that's
what I actually said and everyone was
talking about the value the difference
with now is that yeah at 25 I was hot
do you know I mean I was hot slim hot
that's nah you are that is fully myself
I look hot for somebody of 53. do you
want me to act fooling myself that I
look as hot as I am at 53 years I did at
25. yeah I'm just the exception is that
the same man that I was with at 25 is
the same thing that I was with now dude
I mean but other than that no and I
agree that and I'm not fooling myself to
say that you know I mean I was lucky
enough that he had my best years and
he's still got my best years and I had
his the best years but at the end of the
day I can't turn around and say I'm
better off for anybody else at 53
because anybody else at 53 months when
they got a wedding ring on they'd be
married or something like that by the
end of the day if it weren't for a fluke
I'm just like everybody else yeah I'm a
leftover in a committed relationship and
that's what women feel to realize that
yes before you think about oh I'm going
to be single I'm going to be this and
I'm going to be that you've got to fix
yourself you know what
because before I started thinking like
that I was like you know I've got to get
my pension I gotta get my own house I
gotta get the house done in case I'm
disabled I gotta get my will go get my
LPA because just in case you end up on
your own and you know something 32 years
and I'm still got that mindset you know
what because I'm still left over because
I've still got to think like that so I'm
gonna affecting myself yeah I've been
with the guy for like 30 something years
I've got so I've got to still think like
that you know what because I don't know
you're doing your right thing because
fool myself and say I've got the same
Worth to him as I was years ago or I
look you know I mean oh yeah you're a
hot time
so the goal is marriage then is that the
goal should always be marriage because
that's when you know a guy is committed
to you and that's why I said you can be
a woman for today I was talking the
other week and I was saying a man could
be with you for 30 years 40 years 50
years whatever so there's a ring on your
fingers not committed to you you can
step out so you said you've been with
the same person that you've been with
since you were 25 no before that yeah
since you were before 25 and did you
have kids or no we got two separate
children you've got two so you've not
had kids together since since you no we
haven't okay
that's interesting yeah and I can go
around and say oh yes when I was 35 I
look really good and we could try and
have children together come on by the
time you're 35. you think yourself yeah
I could have better kid at 35 of him but
then you gotta think to yourself how old
am I going to be when I got the kid goes
Nursery am I we're all gonna be winning
I'm gonna go and pick up my grandkids
now I don't want to be gone picking up
my child and they say who's that is that
your grandma no it's my mummy and then
nowadays you're thinking about secondary
school or university I don't want to be
in those 70 years old I'm going to
picking up my child and say oh yeah they
graduate and you're playing with fire
because
um the average if you want to freeze
your eggs and go that route like that it
costs like twenty five thousand dollars
there's no guarantee it'll work the
average person can afford that no I'm
just thinking it's interesting because
you said you were together from before
you were 21st or what like 22 23 about
that yeah
and then but you you were in the like
you guys said the best years of your
life whatever and still didn't have kids
still having them
sorry you're still I'm still having that
no no I'm just going by what these I'm
saying by the word by the worst from the
they said I wouldn't have a child from
35 onwards so according to a man if a
man wants to have a child and that that
would have been the time to get to have
a child then not like 30 Because by the
time 30 comes we're like forget it you
know what I mean forget it because I'm
putting my body through that and buy a
pod according what um said your name
again KB KB he said especially when a
woman has a child with the before
that's the best year also because this
has very strong a close relationship
between you know the your your baby uh
dad and yourself right so but you are
actually just showing that that's not
true so yeah because the differences you
don't know my story the difference is is
that I had an abusive relationship
that's why I've got no Hangouts there's
a completely different if it was a happy
relationship and I had my son and we
left that'd be different by number one I
was on contraception when I had my son
so he wasn't planned and because of that
reason that's why I decided to have one
child because I will say one is a
mistake two can say is an accident three
is K there's four and above your white
list
so as far as I'm concerned I had one out
of wedlock and that is it yeah but
anyway you add a child and your partner
evaluate you anyways as a valuable
valuable women so he actually spent
after the best here with you in this
scenario
no I mean this is just compromise
that what you guys saying it doesn't
happen
at the age at between like say was a 20
between that 20 and 30. I'm agreeing if
I wasn't with him and I spent what
they're trying to say is that if I had
met him at 30 why should he be faithful
to me when I've given my best years to
some other man if I stayed with my baby
father yeah until I was 30 and then said
you know what I'm gonna get back with
the first one the one I'm with now why
should he be monogamous why should he
stay with me because you have a lot of
stuff giving up my good life my good the
best of my life when I was young free
sexy agile fling my legs over my
shoulders was all between the ages of
twenties
you don't have the youth and you don't
have the Purity at 30. it's gone so it's
you don't have what men value okay as I
said a festival right now uh 20 years
old like girl cannot have Purity anymore
because they probably lose the virginity
when they 12 but let's forget about it
so if that the point that means that
every woman that uh as child a child
before Oh yes relationship important
relationship people could not have a
husband later and I saw a lot of people
that actually ADD child before and after
they get married or whatever so what do
you mean that uh demand that actually
you know wifey air is uh I don't know
it's a bomb like or a bomb well man
don't I don't care about your job like
you could like you could do nothing and
like men do not give a like because
you said earlier like I make money and
I'm like well not to men that's like a
shoe collection to women like if a guy
if a guy says if a guy says oh I have a
cool shoe shoe collection we're like oh
that's then we keep moving that's how
men feel about work okay
they'd prefer a girl that like does
nothing so she can like hang out with
them and like don't on them
good yeah I mean one person can get
married unemployed not two
yeah
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible